One day to day life. This kind. Very big street has moved up to great great.
What are you really like you know what are the right places like. You must be doing very well.
DOING THE RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. That will never be one that was probably the case.
Yet I see there for a not that you should join US market for your.
What the Russians do to this day cancel what you know we did you not that I did not. Yes it was.
If there's a safe place you send their kids.
That said you're going to do this we can use them leave and then you saw a little bit out there that that's the way.
Right right here right.
Why did that throw a baby right there just like that
or the neighborhood spend a fortune that you paid for you right away you were out where yeah yeah.
Where you and I would. Right. So it's probably just a story with a great story.
Just get right when you look at the individuals just about religion if you don't really get what they say oh wait.
Through banks where a radical thought that if you can get it right.
That man is in there trying to work Saturday morning.
But you know that guy is already here and I thought before you know before.
Both of you get caught up are you going to blow your stack size trying to get very high stop me from drag stuff.
This way so seriously. We just used to do was get a check.
Because it was quick to raise that was we thought it would do yes.
Then I remember right here I'll be all right this time. Oh God hears her cry cry she she's going to stop me.
Yeah you know. All right on that one very good. It was a Science Show a monster and she's with us.
How do you know if you're right Johnny she said I think it's this Christ the way the Salvation Army.
How do you know the Straits intellect. Oh he's right here.
There's a risk if we go through with it seems pretty easy no people just see the year of easy so he did have.
Yeah yeah you. You know the real me was that the right. Everybody thought oh no they're all right. Child.
This is not the first man no real bright guy. Yes. Yeah. And what's not.
Why don't I just get up and they fight about that ancestor they say you know what.
I mean that they need some system through the last year where he carried sign language with you know just fine.
Yeah yeah. Mr Dering missed the whole miss in the West Bank but it was something right there right.
They enter a second base pretty good there. That's not really directly there right now where not used to.
Well I used to say
when the he was in so many different states we used to go where my mate where there used again War lasers
and I was just really brought out of the hole or he saw the whole thing My Space will be what he had always worried
and when little guys when you're really not rusty got very busy. Drain nature mean nothing to trade with.
Well we probably get there then try the old boy she saw that we are working.
And they were nice guys not that hard and instead they have a year and then what used to have a place we share right.
And I used to get pissed off to say if we had pineapple you know the next time some crazy was cured of.
That maybe it will be something. You just know you might do.
That is just before the six o'clock was before where the thing. Not even got a five zero or that. Or the. All Russians.
I hear they yank your trade you know that it's a lot of a lot to go after what Mo Mo Mo just to that night not right.
They don't have that.
Oh I say Have you seen the last ago that you gave where I think that was probably one of the reasons you got to fall in
love with the world and that's what I mean in my life.
So you probably know I said kid would fade away with a very low key all the way he was because of the summer nights I
always say he was the one man you know again just lay there you know just result. Do you play with us.
We're very nice guys you know like me which in your gut. If you to transform the sector or in your new Gyptian Hood.
Type type of a ha war I might work for six months but you always have reached a new method you love
and you're seriously Summerson day and night even that you're hired actually through the night I live it.
The sign would warn that you can't read when you know exactly how much that counts. My feathers my heavy.
Have it on my head just like an injection or sort of the city. My everything in this.
This is that this is still going on here yes. Yeah yeah yeah just like that.
Let me just say that this is the party and this is Mark Foley and this
and this is what everybody thought it was that's right. You know this got me sick. And that's right Carol.
Yes this is true and that's. Yeah you know when you get this today. And that's that's that helps it get to you.
One head to head. You get a flight. And that's when we got into this story.
Was there with the plane did you go this way or was that second that landed in the right. That was way beyond.
Now that's just how it's always been see you. I just thought it was a great just to have a. That's right Lou.
That's right. We were all for the last say hey you know what you have a great. You're going to be push back. You know.
Well this is really good. Yeah they're like you know with everybody. What can I do with you say you to shoot.
What was the. Goal here in the race. To get you know. There was no way. It was done it was done. That's me.
Now it's time you got that one.